who we would send Revelation
two and if you do not know,
then ask the people of
knowledge. The people of
knowledge here, meaning the
people of the books.
the Christians, the Jews who
were known for their
scholarship in the time of the
prophet
and not only known for their
scholarship but
of Mecca the idolaters of Mecca
would often consult the Jews of
Madinah and elsewhere with
regards to religious issues.
So, for instance, the people of
Mecca prior to the prophet used
to fast the day of Ashura. This
was something that they did in
Mecca. Why did they do that?
Well, there's a couple of
reasons. Some of the scholars
mentioned that this was part of
the religion of Ibrahim Alaihi
Salam that was remnant amongst
them. Others mentioned that the
people of Mecca felt that they
had committed a major
collective sin. And they wished
to do something to appease
Allah to who kind of rectify
the sin that they had committed
and so they had asked some of
the Jews of Medina with regards
to a worship that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala loves and
they inform them of the day of
Ashura. Though this seems to be
the weaker opinion, it is an
opinion and a valid opinion of
some historians of Islam. Point
being here is that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala referenced
the prophet and all of the
prophets that came before him
in the previous books and his
previous revelations. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said and
these men that we have sent
Revelation two, they were not
unique in their
in their
anatomic in the anatomic sense.
They were human beings. They
ate food. They drank water.
They walked amongst people.
They had necessities as people
do. They suffered from
tiredness and sleep and the
things that people, human
beings have as part of their
nature. As well, they are
susceptible to illness as
people are, susceptible,
etcetera.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
and we have not made them
just empty vessels, empty
bodies that do not need to. Do
not need to eat food or be
nourished nor did we give them
everlasting life. Meaning, they
all were taken by death as
human beings are. There's no
in that sense. There may be a
difference in the manner of
death and the experience of
death, obviously. However,
death in the general sense is
something that is common, is a
commonality between all human
beings. Good and bad people,
prophets, and and martyrs and
wicked people. All of them have
the commonality of death. The
commonality of the need for
nourishment, for food, for
drink, the commonality of
susceptibility to illness, and
tiredness, and exhaustion, and
sleep, etcetera. There are some
stories floating around. In
which it's mentioned that
roaming the earth. After all of
these years and that he comes
and goes and meets people and
people, you know, kind of
narrates all of these strange
narrations that this man came
and he told us one, two, three,
and he helped us with our horse
or he helped us with our boat
and then he went on his way or
he helped us in this battle or
these stories are all suspect.
These stories are all.
incorrect, and any narration
having to do with thee
continuing life of Al Qadar,
which are ascribed to the
prophet are all fabrications.
The prophet never said this.
Authentically anywhere.
and if Al Qadr was still alive,
he would be expected to come to
the prophet. he would be
expected to make Hajj. He would
be expected to pledge
allegiance to the prophet
during his time. He would be
expected to come and follow the
prophet Muhammad's religion and
be with him and with his
companions, rather than roaming
all over the world, not really
teaching anybody anything about
Allah and just kind of running
round doing running small
errands for people. This is
kind of silly. When we say it
that but that is what it
boils down to.
For NJ Narem,
Al
[Silence]
promises to them Our promises,
meaning Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala promised them many
things. And the chief of those
that they would be spared and
saved from the wrath of their
people. There's a difference
between prophets and
messengers. and The word
messenger in the diction of the
Quran is far more specific than
the word prophet. Because every
prophet, because every
messenger is a prophet. But not
every prophet is a messenger. A
messenger is an additional an
additional virtue, an
additional trait that not all
prophets have. There is a
narration in Imam Ahmed.
in which it was mentioned that
the prophet was asked how many
prophets were there? And he
said, 1 24000. How many
messengers? Three hundred and
fifteen. This narration, though
it has been criticized by some
scholars of hadith. The spirit
of its meaning is correct. And
that is, that, messengers are
far less numerous than
prophets. So, what is the
difference between a prophet
and a messenger?
a prophet and a messenger both
have revelation come to them.
from Allah However, a messenger
is
given a message given
revelation by Allah and
commanded to deliver that
revelation to a people who are
fundamentally opposed to it.
Meaning, a prophet, a messenger
is not sent to a people who are
already, who are already
Muslim, or already upon the
religion of their previous
messenger. Prophets are sent
for that task. Messengers are
sent to a people who are
fundamentally opposed to that
message Messengers are sent to
idolaters, messengers are sent
to people who are disbelievers,
no no longer upon the religion
of their, of their respective
messenger of prophet.
However, prophets maybe may
have been sent to just as
prophets, not as messengers.
Two, people who were in
accordance with the generality
of their of their messengers,
religion. Though they may have
strayed or the religion needs,
needs to be revived. Some
scholars mentioned that the a
prophet is upon thee legis of
the messenger that precedes
him. This is one opinion If we
look at Musa Alaihi Salam, he
was a messenger. If we look at
Dawood Alaihi Salam, Zakaria,
yeah yeah These were prophets
The prophet Muhammad said
Muslim
[Silence]
a messenger prophets would pass
away. Another prophet would be
appointed. We see here in the
dua of Zacharia. This is very
clear. In Zakaria is making and
praying to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala for a son that would
take his place after he passes
away. At his old age and he was
given Yahia Alaihi Salam. These
are prophets. Prophets are
subject to harm from their
people and sometimes even they
are killed by their people.
Messengers, however, are not
killed. Messenger are protected
by Allah and they see their
message through. Their people
will either become Muslim or
they will be delivered by Allah
and their antagonist will be
destroyed. As is in the case
with the majority of
messengers, though we do have
instances such as,
The prophet Muhammad
These are messengers whom their
people became Muslim.
for the most part but we have
other messengers Ibrahim,
Lut, Noah, Hud,
and Shahib. None of these
people became Muslim. They were
Muslim, they were believers,
some very few of their people
became Muslim, but the majority
of their people remained in
disbelief. As Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala says
[Silence]
and